Ross: Good afternoon,
everybody.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Max Ross.
I'm a software engineer on
the App Engine team at Google.
I focus primarily on things
related to persistence.
I work on the App Engine
Datastore,
the common piece
of infrastructure
that's behind persistence
for both the Python and Java
run times.
I also work on the Java
low-level Datastore API
and I also work on the JDO/JPA
implementation
that we provided for persistence
in Java.
And today we're going
to be talking about
the softer side of schemas.
So before we jump in,
let me give you a brief overview
of what you can expect
from today's talk.
Just a quick show of hands,
how many people here
have already built
and deployed an application
on App Engine?
All right, lots of hands.
And how many have done Python?
And how many have done Java?
All right, I like to see
all those Java hands.
That's great.
Okay, so just to make sure
that we all have
the same foundation,
I'm gonna spend a couple
of minutes talking about
some of the fundamentals
of the App Engine Datastore
and then we're going to build
on top of that.
From there we're going
to move to a discussion
of soft schemas.
And obviously I owe you
a definition of that term
and I will provide one.
But we're gonna talk about
soft schemas
and how you can use existing
Java persistence standards,
specifically JDO and JPA,
to implement a soft schema
on top of the App Engine
Datastore.
And then we're going
to go through some strategies
for migrating existing
applications onto App Engine,
and then some strategies for
moving App Engine applications
off of App Engine--not that you
would ever want to do that.
Actually we know that you would
want to do that
and that's why we put
a lot of thought
into making sure that
that's gonna work nicely.
And then we'll finish up
with some questions.
So, let's talk about
the basics of the App Engine
Datastore.
First and foremost,
it is transactional.
It has the acid properties
that we have rightly
come to expect
from something
that does persistence.
A little bit more
interestingly,
it is natively partitioned.
The App Engine Datastore
is a distributed system.
Your data is split out
across a network of servers.
And unlike an architecture
where you have
horizontally partitioned
your data,
and maybe it's the
responsibility of your code
to decide at runtime
where data is gonna go,
the App Engine Datastore
is natively partitioned.
We're going to split
your data up for you.
So just by building
your application
on top of the Datastore,
this is going to happen.
That's pretty cool.
Another interesting aspect
of the Datastore
is that it's hierarchical.
Every entity that you store
in the Datastore
can have a notion of its parent
or its grandparent
or its great grandparent,
or it can be one
of these entities
that we like to call
a root entity
where it doesn't have
a parent at all.
But this is baked
into the Datastore itself.
It's a native feature.
Another interesting aspect,
it is schema-less.
So the Datastore does not have
any notion
of the structure of your data.
And we're gonna talk
a lot more about this
as we go forward.
And then finally
it is based on Bigtable,
which is a distributed
storage system
that Google has developed
over the years
that we run for you.
A couple of things
that I want to point out
that the Datastore isn't--
It isn't
a relational database,
and I really want to make
this point clear.
The Datastore isn't
a relational database.
It's not a SQL engine.
In this talk we're gonna
be discussing how JDO and JPA,
these Java persistence
standards--
which are commonly used to talk
to a relational database--
we're gonna talk about
how these persistence standards
can also be used to talk
to the App Engine Datastore.
But that does not mean
that the App Engine Datastore
is a relational database.
So, here's a quote
from my friend Z,
who I sometimes ride
the Google bus with
up to San Francisco.
We were talking about App Engine
one day
and I was describing
the Datastore to him
and he said, "I don't want
a relational database
for my application,
I just want persistence."
Now I know not everybody
in this room
is going to agree
with that sentiment.
And it makes sense
that some people will agree
and some people don't.
But I want to say that for those
of you that agree with Z,
you're gonna be really excited
about working
with the Datastore because
it really does simplify things.
One of our primary
design goals here
is to simplify storage.
We want to simplify
the development of applications
that require storage
and we want to simplify
the management of applications
that require storage.
Now the reason our solution
looks the way it does
is that throughout App Engine
as a whole,
the entire product,
we sort of have a history
of taking existing
infrastructure services
that already exist
within Google--
these are the types of services
that allow you to send mail,
that allow you
to fetch the contents
of a URL on the Internet--
we have a long history
of building these services
in a way that scales
and in a way that we know how
to manage them very efficiently
so that the people
who consume these services
don't have to worry
about managing them efficiently.
Sorry, distracted by beeping.
The Datastore
is no different.
So why are we
exposing Bigtable?
We're exposing Bigtable
because we're really good
at running this service.
And this is a big part
of simplifying the management
of applications
that need storage.
So for those of you
who might be thinking,
"Well, I've heard that Bigtable
is a storage solution
"for applications that need
to scale to Google scale,
to the size of Gmail,
for example."
I'd like to try
and make the point
that no matter what type
of application you're building,
scale always matters.
It might not need to scale
to the size of Gmail,
but you have some target scale
in mind.
It might be 5 concurrent users
or 20 concurrent users
or 100 or 1,000,
but every single one
of those targets involves
certain design decisions
that you need to think about.
So it's not just that
App Engine
is for building applications
that need to scale
to the same size
as Google applications.
It's for building applications
that are going to scale
to whatever that scaling target
might be more easily.
That's one of the things
we're trying to simplify here.
So let's look
at the storage model.
The basic thing
that we are persisting here
is something called an Entity.
And an Entity
has four components.
There's a kind,
which for those of you coming
from the relational database
world
would probably think of this
as the table.
It has a key, which you can
think of as the primary key.
There is the Entity Group,
which is part of every
single Entity.
And this goes into determining
what partition
your data's gonna live on.
If you've done horizontal
partitioning before,
or sharding as we like
to call it,
this term will be familiar
to you.
We use this to figure out
what data
this Entity is co-located with.
And then finally you have
some number of typed properties
which you can think
of as columns.
So here we have an example
where the person is a kind.
And if you'll notice here
the Entity Group and the key
are the same.
Anytime you see an Entity
where the Entity Group
and the key are the same,
that means you're looking
at a root entity.
It doesn't have a parent.
We talked about the Datastore
being hierarchical before.
If the Entity Group
and the key are the same,
it doesn't have a parent.
It's a root Entity.
And then in this example
we have two properties.
We can see that Ethel
is 30 years old
and Ethel has a best friend
named Sally.
This bottom column here,
the best friend,
you can see that it's referring
to another key.
You can think of that
if you're coming
from the relational world
as a foreign key.
The Datastore does support this.
So let's talk about some
of the interesting features
that you get
with the Datastore
that you might not
be accustomed to.
First and foremost,
there is this hierarchical
nature of the Datastore.
In the top right-hand corner
here
we have the same person
as before.
We have Ethel
whose best friend is Sally.
But then on the bottom,
we have a person Entity
that is a child of Ethel.
And the way that we know
that this person Entity
is a child of Ethel
is we can look at the key.
And we can see that the key
consists of the parent Ent--
the key of the parent Entity
with the key of the child
appended to it.
We have person Ethel,
person Jane.
This uniquely identifies
this Entity and tells us
that it's a child.
And then if we look
at the Entity group,
we can see that the Entity Group
and the key
are not the same.
This is therefore a child Entity
residing in the same
Entity Group as Ethel.
So that's how we see ancestors
sort of played out
in the physical model.
The Datastore also supports
heterogeneous property types.
On the Ethel Entity we can see
that the type
of the age property
is an Int64.
Ethel is 30.
But Jane here
is a little bit younger
and maybe likes to describe
her age in terms of half years,
so we can represent that
as a double.
Because the Datastore
is schema-less,
there's no problem representing
age as an Int in one record
and age as a double
in another record.
We also support
multi-value properties.
Ethel, this 8 1/2-year-old,
has multiple best friends.
We can store this in a very
natural way in the Datastore.
If you've run
into this situation
with a relational database
before,
you usually have two choices.
You can either sort of
break that multiplicity out
into a separate table or--
and I'm guilty
of having done this
in the past--
you can put data
in sort of, like,
you can have some logical
structure there
where you can separate
the data with commas.
And you can say, "Okay,
well, yeah,
it's a multi-value property."
I can't query for it
because the querying mechanism
doesn't understand
the implicit structure
that you've baked in there,
but it is a way to sort of
fake multi-value properties.
With the Datastore you can do
this in a really natural way.
It works great.
And then the final thing
I want to point out
is that Jane,
this child record here,
has a grade property.
Jane's parent Ethel
doesn't have a grade property.
So it's perfectly acceptable
for one Entity
of kind person to have
a certain set of properties
and another Entity
of kind person
to have a different set
of properties.
I want to talk about
transactions a little bit.
This going to play
an important role
in the discussion
of soft schemas
and JDO/JPA persistence mapping
that's coming along.
So I want to make sure everybody
has a good understanding
of what Datastore transactions
are and how they work.
I described the Entity Group
before
as sort of a partition key.
And one of the reasons
this is important
is that you can only transact
on Entities
that belong to the same
Entity Group.
So if you look
at the example here,
we can see that we have
Ethel and Jane belonging
to the same Entity Group,
but then person Max here belongs
to a different Entity Group.
What this means is I can make
an update to Ethel
and I can make an update
to Jane
and I can have that update
succeed or fail atomically.
But if I add an update
to Max into that mix
and I try to commit
the transaction,
I'm gonna get an exception back
because I'm trying to perform
an atomic operation
that spans Entity Groups.
So soft schemas.
Here's the definition.
A soft schema is a schema
whose constraints
are enforced purely
in the application layer.
What do I mean by that?
Well, this is a scenario
where your applications'
expectations of the structure
and the validation
that's been applied to the data,
that is the schema itself.
And when you're working
with a Datastore
like the App Engine Datastore
that does not have
a schema baked in,
this can be really valuable
because this takes you
from an area
where perhaps you're used
to having the database
do a lot of this validation
and provide this structure
for you
into an area that looks a little
bit more familiar, right?
You have to give up
some of that structure
when you move
to the App Engine Datastore.
But if there's some way
to implement a soft schema
on top of it,
then you're back in the area
where things look maybe
a little bit more
like what you're used to.
So we actually get some nice
things out of a soft schema.
First and foremost,
well, when you don't have
a schema at all,
if any of you have worked
with sort of the low-level API
in the Datastore,
you've probably seen how easy
it is to rapidly prototype
an application
that requires persistence.
And that's great.
That rapid prototyping
is great.
But I'm a Java guy
and I love type safety.
So I would like to have
the ability
to do that rapid iteration
and that rapid prototyping
but do it in a typesafe way.
So having a soft schema
where I actually have
some structure to my data
encoded in the application,
that's gonna give me
that type safety
but still give me
the flexibility
to do that rapid prototyping.
The other argument I want
to make in favor of soft schemas
has to do with sort
of consistency throughout
your development process.
I've been on projects before
where we're developing
a web application in Java.
We're using a relational
database
as our storage solution.
And we typically find ourselves
doing things two different ways.
So what goes into developing
this application?
Well, we need to write code.
We want to have unit tests.
We want to have different
deployment environments,
development, QA, staging,
integration, production
and so on.
And we find ourselves
sort of replicating that process
for Java and then we find
ourselves replicating
that process for managing
the database.
We have to manage our seed data.
We have to manage our schema.
And then we have to figure out
a way to unit test
that migration code
that we've written.
And so it's these parallel ways
of accomplishing
the same thing.
And I'm not saying
it's not possible
to get to a point where
you can do that efficiently.
What I am saying is that
it takes effort,
and oftentimes you end up
maybe cutting corners
on one of those sides.
And it's usually
on the database side.
If you are using a soft schema,
you have the opportunity--
in a sense it's sort
of a forcing function.
It forces you
to do everything related
to managing the structure
and the content
of your Datastore the same way.
So you can write your code
in Java.
You can write
your business logic in Java.
If you're using GWT,
you can write your front end
in Java.
And now, of course
you could do this before,
but now we're sort of
forcing you a little bit
to manage your data in Java.
The benefit you get from that
is you're doing everything
the same way.
And I think there's a lot
of benefit to consistency
in a software development
life cycle.
So how are we going
to implement
a soft schema on top
of the Datastore?
Well, it turns out
in the Java world
we are fortunate enough
to have not just one
but two persistence standards.
We have JDO and JPA.
And just a quick show of hands,
who here is familiar
with either JDO or JPA?
Okay, so a fair number of hands.
Really quick definition
or a really quick explanation
of JDO and JPA.
These are transparent
persistence frameworks.
The idea is that
you take your model object
from your application--
let's say it's
a bug-tracking system,
so you might have a bug object,
and you provide some meta-data
for that bug object
that describes how that object
is supposed to be persisted.
And typically you provide
that meta-data
either using annotations
or XML
and then you have this framework
behind the scenes
that knows how to interpret
that meta-data
and take that object and persist
it in some sort of Datastore.
So JDO and JPA are both
Java persistence standards
for getting this type
of transparent persistence.
Now what I'm gonna argue
is that JDO and JPA
effectively give you
a soft schema definition.
How do I know that they do it?
Well, if you've used pretty much
any ORM out there--
you've used Hibernate or TopLink
or DataNucleus--
they all come with
these roundtrip tools, right?
The can take your Java objects
that you've provided
the meta-data for
and spit out a relational
database schema
based on that meta-data, right?
So if those
round-trip tools exist,
if there's enough information
encoded in the meta-data
that you provided to generate
a relational database schema,
there must be enough information
in that meta-data
to define what the structure
and the constraints
that your application expects.
So JDO and JPA,
just by using them
the way that you would normally
use them, are going
to give you this additional
structure to your application,
which is gonna turn
the Datastore
from something that maybe looks
a little bit different
because it doesn't have
a schema
into something that looks
a lot more like
what you're used to.
Something that has--
we can call them tables
and columns.
We know from looking
at the physical model
which we already went through
that they're not actually
tables and columns,
but you can draw
that connection there.
The other great thing
that we get from this
beyond the soft schema is we get
to write our persistence code
using established Java APIs.
And there's huge value in this.
If you already know
how to use JDO and JPA,
and you understand what
the interfaces are,
that's one less thing
for you to learn
when you're trying to build
an application on App Engine.
That's hugely valuable.
Another great thing is if
you've used JPA or JDO recently
and you use an IDE,
there's built-in tooling
for these things already.
If you create an Entity
in Eclipse or Intelliday
and you set it up incorrectly,
you're gonna get
the little red squiggle
that says, "Hey,
you're doing it wrong."
It takes a long time.
Doesn't take a long--
depending on the technology,
it can sometimes take a while
for sort of
the tooling ecosystem
around a new technology
to get built up.
But because we're using things
that have already
been around for a while,
a lot of that tooling exists.
That's, again,
hugely valuable.
The reason that I'm happiest--
the reason I'm most happy
about this, though,
is when it comes to porting.
It's really important to us
on the App Engine team
that you have the flexibility
to take your code
someplace else
if App Engine
isn't meeting your needs.
We obviously want you to take
existing code and bring it on.
We want you to try it out.
But it's important to us
that you not feel locked in
once you're there.
And using these existing
persistence standards
really goes a long way
towards making it easier
to take your code
someplace else.
That really is
important to us,
and we're gonna go through
some examples
later on in the talk
for some strategies
of how to do that.
So it turns out--
we looked at JDO and JPA.
We said, "Okay, this is great.
"We can get a soft schema
from this.
"This is gonna make
the Datastore look
"a little bit more familiar
to people.
"We're gonna get
the established APIs.
"We're gonna get the tooling.
It's gonna be easier to port,
but will it work?"
There's these existing standards
and they were not designed
with platform
as a service in mind.
The did not have
the App Engine Datastore
in mind when they were designing
these specifications.
So does it actually line up?
And the answer is mostly yeah.
It's a pretty good fit.
Turns out the specifications
are mostly mappable
to Datastore features and
that the Datastore features--
some of these interesting
features that I described
a few minutes ago--
those features are actually
mostly mappable
to the specifications.
So we're gonna go through
some examples of how
to surface some of these
Datastore-specific features
through Java persistence
standards.
So here's an example of how
we can do an ancestor query
using JPA.
You'll notice we have--
so this is a JPA entity here.
Here's an address,
and let's assume
that an address is owned
by a person, right?
So we have a
one-to-many relationship
from person to address.
And I haven't shown you
the entire class here
because it would be
too much code to read.
But we do have a key, right?
This is an App Engine-specific
primary key class,
which you can use.
You don't have to use it,
but in this case
just for clarity we're using it.
Here is a key
that uniquely identifies
the person
that owns the address.
If you were modeling this
in the relational database
world,
you could think of this
as a composite primary key.
By using this extension
annotation,
which is not an App Engine
specific annotation--
this is actually something
that DataNucleus understands.
By using this annotation,
we can tell the App Engine
JDO/JPA implementation,
"Hey, this is a parent.
This is part of an ancestor."
And when you query
based on this field,
we can recognize that and say,
"Oh, the field
that they're querying by
"is a parent primary key.
Let me execute
an ancestor query."
And so you can see
that this query down here
which is just standard
JPA query,
there's nothing special
about it.
But we're interpreting it
in a special way
because of this annotation.
Filtering by multi-value
properties.
This is a really, really nice
and natural way
to express a query.
So now we're looking
at a JDO example
where we have a person
and a person has some number
of hobbies.
And we can just say,
"Select from person
where hobbies contains yoga."
Give me everybody who considers
yoga a hobby.
This works and this
is a really natural way
to express one
of the nicest features
that you get from running
on the Datastore.
Transactions.
This is a little bit trickier.
The API for transactions
in JDO and JPA
is a nice fit with the API
for transactions
in the Datastore.
It's basically begin,
commit, or roll back.
So syntactically
we're in good shape,
but semantically it gets
a little bit more difficult,
and the reason is because
of the nature
of transactions which
I described before.
How with the Datastore
you can only transact
within an Entity Group.
If you're coming from
the relational database world,
you're probably used
to global transactions,
where you can update any record
in your database
and you can say "commit"
and that's totally fine.
So how do we bridge
this gap?
Well, we're gonna look
at some strategies later on.
I just want to sort
of point out that there
is this difference here.
But the other thing
that I want to point out
is that the challenge
that we're facing right here
is really no different
than the challenge we face
when we are sharding our data
anyway.
So if you are splitting
your data
across multiple relational
databases,
you are going to face
a similar challenge.
You don't have global
transactions anymore
because you have data
that lives on this server
and you have data that lives
on this server.
So you can't just do
one global transaction here
and expect to be able
to atomically update
something over there.
What's the solution?
It's two phase commit.
And as some of you might
have seen
in Dan Wilkerson's talk
yesterday,
he has a working algorithm
for two phase commit
on the App Engine Datastore.
So the problem is similar
to what you get
with horizontal partitioning.
The solution is similar
to what you get
with horizontal partitioning.
Let's talk about
relationship management.
And this is not
a self-help course.
We're talking about
JDO and JPA here.
This is some of the most
powerful stuff that--
and I'm gonna use
the word ORM.
JDO and JPA are essentially
standards for ORMs
and the "R" in ORM
stands for relational.
And that's confusing because
we're not actually talking
about anything relational here.
But it's a common term, so...
JDO and JPA are standards
for ORM.
And I've spoken
with a sizeable number
of developers over the years
who say,
"I don't like ORM.
"I don't like giving up
the control
over what gets fetched
and what gets updated."
And I totally understand that.
It is fairly easy to have
a lot of things going on
under the hood with an ORM.
And some people really want
to stay close to the metal.
The point that I want
to try to make here
is that JDO and JPA
have a lot of value
beyond sort of all the magic
that it will do under the hood
related to relationship
management.
By relationship management,
I'm talking about the fact
that you can declare
a one-to-many relationship
and you can just sort of add
something to a collection,
and because it's reachable
from something
that's already persisted
it will automatically
get written to the Datastore.
The fact that you can touch
some object
which hasn't been loaded
by the Datastore yet
and the framework will say,
"Oh, this thing hasn't
been loaded,"
and it will pull it
into memory, right?
That's
the kind of stuff
that people can easily
get tangled up in.
And the point that I want
to make
is that you don't have
to take advantage
of all of that stuff
to find JDO and JPA useful.
The biggest benefit,
I think,
that you get
from these technologies
is the fact that you have
a centralized mapping
for the meta-data
of your model objects, right?
It's not scattered around
your application
in a bunch of properties files
that have SQL statements
or Java files that are doing--
that have JDVC code.
It's centralized,
either in XML meta-data or
in annotations on your object.
That is a big
maintainability win.
And just using that alone,
right, you get the soft schema.
You get the familiar APIs.
You get the tooling.
You get the portability.
And you don't even have
to touch
the relationship management
stuff.
Now, that said, I also
want to encourage you
to try and take advantage
of the relationship management
stuff.
And the reason is that
on the App Engine Datastore,
this becomes more important.
It becomes more important
than it might be
if you were using
a relational database.
The reason is that
relational databases
have foreign key constraints.
So when you have a one-to-many
relationship between,
say, person and address,
and you want to store
the primary key of the person
that owns an address
on the address table,
you have a foreign key there
and if you add something
to that person ID column
on the address table
that if you set it to null
and it's not nullable,
or you're referencing
a person ID that doesn't exist,
the database is going to catch
that mistake and say "no."
But the App Engine Datastore
is schema-less, right?
We're gonna be more flexible
about things.
But if you let JDO and JPA
take care
of the relationship management,
they're gonna make sure that
these things get set properly.
Now you can write this code
yourself.
And typically what happens
is you write it yourself once.
You write it yourself
a second time.
a third time.
All of these different
situations,
you probably get them
mostly right.
And then at the fourth time,
you say,
"Man, I'm sick of writing
this code.
"I'm gonna write
a small framework
to take care of it for me."
And the next thing you know
we have our 18th ORM
that's available
on SourceForge.
So letting the framework
manage relationships for you
is particularly important
when you're using
the App Engine Datastore
because
there are no foreign key
constraints.
The other big win, and for me
this is the killer feature--
I'm gonna try to convince you
that this is cool and useful.
The killer feature here
is transparent Entity Group
management.
Deciding what Entity Groups
your objects
are going to reside in
is one
of the most important
design decisions
that you're going to make
when you're building
an App Engine application.
And there's some tension here,
right?
It's tension between
write throughput
and atomic updates.
There is a limit on how often
you can update something
that lives in an Entity Group.
It's approximately 1 to 10
writes per second
within a single Entity group.
But on the other hand,
the only way that you can update
multiple objects atomically
is if they live in the same
Entity Group.
All right, so you might say,
"Okay, well I want to have
global transaction,
"so let me put everything
in my application
in the same Entity Group."
Okay, but now you're limited
to 1 to 10 writes per second
and you're gonna get lots
of concurrent modification
exceptions.
So there's a balancing act here
and only you know what
the right balance is.
Once you've decided
what that balance is
it's up to you to implement
that in your application
to make sure that these objects
actually go into the correct
Entity Groups.
However, if you use
the relationship management
functionality
that comes with JDO and JPA,
we are going to be able
to assign objects
to appropriate Entity Groups
on your behalf.
So when we talk about
relationships,
we typically refer to them
as either owned or unowned.
And by owned I mean
the child object
doesn't make sense
without its parent.
As an example,
think of a book as a parent
and a chapter as a child.
It doesn't make sense to have
a chapter without a book.
An unowned relationship,
on the other hand,
is something
that can exist perfectly fine
without an owner.
You might have a person
and you have a car,
and you might have
an association
between a person and a car
at some point in time,
but the person could go away
and the car still exists.
It still makes sense and maybe
somebody else owns it
or maybe nobody owns it.
But we could describe that
as an unowned relationship.
So the way that we make
transparent Entity Group
management work
is we let ownership imply
Entity Group co-location.
So here's an example,
and this is a JPA snippet
where we have a person Entity
with a one-to-many relationship
to pet.
And then down below,
we show you what
the physical model looks like
when you set up your model
this way.
I want to point out that
this model,
this is standard JPA code,
right?
There's nothing about
Entity Groups in here.
We've just said @Entity
@OneToMany.
But since @OneToMany tells us
that this
is an owned relationship,
we can use that information
to automatically place pet
in the same Entity Group
as person.
So on the left here we have
person, which is the parent,
and then on the right
we can see that this pet,
pet number 18, its parent key
is this person.
They're sitting there
in this same Entity Group.
So this works great.
This is a powerful way...
to take one of...
the newest...
Entity Groups are a feature
of the Datastore
that you need to understand
in order to be successful
building your application.
But this is a really nice way
for us
to give you some sensible
default values for it
so that you don't have to
contend with it quite as much.
So again, this is along
the lines of taking something
that's maybe
not quite so familiar
and folding it into a concept
that you already understand
to make it a little bit more
familiar.
So why does it say
owned one-to-many today?
Well, let me show you what
I want the future
of owned one-to-many
to look like.
You'll notice that there's
an additional property
on that person Entity there
where the parent actually
has a reference
to the thing that it owns.
Why is this important?
Well, I can think
of two reasons.
First off, if the parent
has a reference to its child,
that opens the door
to a certain subset
of join queries that you can't
otherwise express
using the Datastore.
This lets us issue a query
that says,
"Give me all people--
"Give me a person older than 30
that owns a particular pet."
That is a type of join query
that is otherwise difficult
to express.
The other thing it does
is open the door
to some optimizations.
Wouldn't it be great
if you had a person object
loaded in memory?
You haven't loaded the pets
owned by this person yet
and you can say, "Hey, person,
how many pets do you have?"
If you have all of the pets
that the person owns
as part of the person Entity,
you can answer that question
without making another trip
to the Datastore
issuing another query
to get that answer.
If you don't have
that information,
it's absolutely another trip
to the Datastore.
So there's some nice
optimizations
that this enables for us.
So what's stopping us?
Well...
there is this interesting
constraint in the Datastore
that you can only update
an Entity once in a transaction.
And to be perfectly frank,
this is an implementation detail
that has sort of found its way
out to you.
But it's something that
we have to contend with.
So let's think about
what would be involved
in getting that child key
onto the parent.
First let me explain
the Datastore can do ID
generation for you.
But the only way to get
the Datastore
to generate that ID for you
is to actually save the object.
It's sort of like an identity
column in MySQL
where you insert the record
and when it comes back
it has that value set.
So we need to get the child key
on the parent, right?
So in order to get that child
key we have to save the child.
That's the only way we're
gonna get that ID generated.
But we need to make sure
that the child resides
in the same Entity Group
as its parent.
And the only way to get a child
into the same Entity Group
as its parent
is to construct that key
using the key of the parent.
So we need the key of the parent
before we can save the child.
That means we need
to save the parent first.
Okay, so we can save the person.
We can get the person key back.
We can use that person key
to construct the child key.
We can then save the child,
get the child key,
and then we can set it back
on the person
and we can save it.
Except that's the second update
to the person
in the same transaction.
So we can't do it.
What we need is a get next idea
operation on the Datastore
which fortunately we are
in a good position to add
but it's not there yet.
Once that operation
is available
we can solve this problem,
right?
We can ask the Datastore for,
"Hey, give me the next ID
for a person.
Hey, give me the next ID
for a pet."
Now I can take that pet ID.
I can set it on the person.
I can save the person.
I can save the child.
And I've got what I want
by only updating
the person once
in my transaction.
That's great.
The other thing that
it's important for us to solve--
and I'll be honest,
I don't have as clear a picture
of how we're gonna solve this as
I do for this other scenario--
is unknown relationships.
So we've talked about
how JDO and JPA,
we can use ownership
to imply co-location
within an Entity Group.
Well, JDO and JPA also provide
a really nice way
to express unknown relationship
using the objects themselves,
right?
Instead of just having a key,
you get the object itself
as a member
to model that association.
So we can use an unknown
relationship as a queue
to store these Entities
in separate Entity Groups.
The issue here, though,
is again
you can only transact across
Entities that live
in the same Entity Group.
So if you had a person
and you had a car
and you had an unknown
relationship
between person and car,
but they live
in separate Entity groups,
and you start a transaction,
and you load the person,
and then you load the car,
you get an exception
because you're trying
to do something transactionally
across multiple Entity Groups.
So there's a danger here
of exposing something
that everyone expects to work
in JDO and JPA
and it looks normal except
when you try to do something
totally normal and obvious
with it, it doesn't work.
That's dangerous.
That's not something
that we want to do.
So I don't know what
the right answer here is.
We may need to come up
with something.
The other thing that
it's important for us to do
with the JDO and JPA
implementations
is achieve feature parody
with the Python Datastore API.
Those of you who are familiar
with both
may have noticed
that with Python
it is possible to do
a not equals query.
Or it is possible to do
an in query.
Select star from person where
favorite color
is in blue, yellow, red.
That imbalance
isn't just because, like,
we need to flip some bit
on the Java side.
The Datastore itself
does not natively satisfy
those types of queries.
What we did for Python
because we had a little bit
of extra time
is we implemented those--
we call it in user land.
It's sort of part
of the API layer itself.
There's no reason why
we can't do that for Java.
We just haven't done it yet.
But that's an important step.
And then our JDO and JPA
implementations
are gonna be
a lot more filled out.
So let's talk about
some strategies
for migrating existing code
to App Engine.
And I know I hammered this point
home at the beginning,
but I'm gonna say it again.
The Datastore is not
a relational database.
It is not a drop-in replacement
for a relational database.
So even though we are talking
about Java persistence standards
which are oftentimes used
to persist things
in relational databases,
that does not mean that
the App Engine Datastore
is a relational database.
When you want
to bring code over,
you're going to need to do
a bunch of analysis
of your application.
You're gonna want to look
at your use of primary keys.
at your use of transactions,
of queries, of vendor-specific
features.
And you're gonna need
to come up with a plan.
You're gonna need to think
about data migration as well.
I really can't emphasize
this point enough.
Data migration--
I don't think I've ever
given an estimate
for data migration
that was within 3x of what
it actually ended up being.
It's just one of those things
that always ends up harder
than you expect.
So don't forget about
the data migration.
You may notice that--
and we're going to get into
some more specific advice.
But the advice
that I'm giving so far,
there's actually nothing
App Engine-specific about this.
If you were switching between
any two databases,
there's are exactly
the sorts of things
that you would want to look at
and think about.
So let's talk about
primary keys in particular.
If you have single column
primary keys
that are numbers or strings,
VARCHARs,
that's gonna work pretty nicely.
There's a very straightforward
way to map that on.
Composite keys--
with the Datastore we just have
a notion of a key.
But it is sort
of a composite key
because we do have
a notion of ancestor.
So if your composite key
can be thought of
as an ownership chain,
like a single strand
ownership chain,
then you can take
your composite key
and you can map that
to ancestors and Entity Groups.
That works pretty nicely.
So we have an example here
of a pet object
where we have a composite
primary key consisting
of the pet ID and the person ID.
And then over here on the right
we can see that this maps
to an ancestor chain,
where the top level element
is the person
and the child element
is the pet.
For mapping tables,
you could think
of a mapping table--
and in many cases,
actually, it is--
it contains a composite
primary key
where there isn't a single
chain of ownership, right?
If it's a mapping table,
chances are it's owned
by multiple things.
So this fits really well
with multi-value properties.
So in this example
we have a friendship table
modeling
who is friends with who.
And we can see that person 8
is friends
with person 32 and 34.
And we can translate this nicely
to a multi-value property
called friends
on a person entity.
And it has multiple values.
Person 8 is friends
with person 32 and 34.
Now you may look at this
and say,
"Wait a second.
"That's only a unidirectional
relationship.
"What if I want to model
the fact
"that person 32
is friends with person 8
and then person 34 is friends
with person 8?"
You can do that.
It will work okay
but there are some
more complicated things that you
need to start thinking about,
particularly related
to transactions, right?
Person 8 and person 32 are
in separate Entity Groups.
And let's say I want
to establish
a bidirectional friendship
relationship between them.
That means that I need
to update person 8
in one Entity Group
and person 32
in another Entity Group.
And if I want that
to happen atomically
now I'm in a tough spot because
they're in different
Entity Groups.
So now it's up to me
to decide, well,
is it okay
if the first one succeeds
and the second one fails?
Do I want to roll
the first one back
with a compensating transaction?
Do I want to have something
sweep through
and clean it up later?
There's a little bit more
to it,
which brings us nicely
to our next subject--
what's involved in porting
on transactions.
We talked about
the mismatch before.
How at the Datastore
we have transactions
across Entity Groups
and with relational databases.
If we're not partitioning
our data,
we're typically used to having
global transactions.
So the strategy here
is you want to identify
the roots in your data model.
And if you're building
an online service,
the first place I would
recommend looking is user.
Can you hang all of the data
off of a user
and get reasonable write
throughput?
If that works,
you're in good shape.
It's not gonna work
for everybody,
but it's a good first place
to look.
Once you've identified
the roots in your data model,
you're gonna need to find
the operations
in your application that
transact across multiple roots.
Again, these are the scenarios
where the fact
that transactions apply
to a single Entity Group--
these are the scenarios
where that is going
to force you to do something
a little bit different.
Well, what's it going
to force you to do?
Well, it really depends
on the specific situation.
You need to look
at these scenarios
and figure out what
partial success means.
Is it acceptable?
In the bank account transfer
example,
probably not acceptable.
Partial success is probably
not acceptable.
So what do you do about it?
Well, one option, and I wouldn't
expect anybody at all
to be happy about this,
but one option
is to say, "Well, I'm not
gonna support this anymore."
You're gonna just change
the functionality
of your application.
Better examples,
if partial success is okay--
the fact that
your first update succeeds
and the second one fails
and maybe there's
a little bit
of inconsistency there,
that might be okay.
In which case,
disable your transaction
and move on to the next one.
You're in okay shape.
If that's not acceptable
then, again,
your options are implement
a compensating transaction.
First update.
Second update fails.
Try to roll back
the first update.
You can do that.
Or again,
a background process.
These are the options.
These are the types of things
that you need to think about.
For queries, again, you're gonna
need to analyze your usage.
And the general guidance
that we give people
when we talk to them
when they're coming
to App Engine from
the relational world
is shift processing
from your reads to your writes.
So we don't support
join queries.
But denormalization works great.
It's another way
to get the data you want.
So in this particular example,
we have a typical join.
Select * from person A.
We're gonna join
on the person column
across person and A
and then we're going to filter
some property of person
and some property of address.
Typical join query.
If we denormalize
storing information about
the address
on the person itself,
we're duplicating that data,
then we can issue a much more
straightforward query.
So we've shifted the processing
from writes,
because now
when we write a person
we also need to write
information about the address.
And when we update the address
we also need to update
the person.
We've duplicated that data
so we're pushing the processing
onto the writes.
But that's going to allow us
to do a really efficient read.
For other operations--things
like toUpper, for example--
you want to do a query
and you want to match
on the upper case version
of some column
that's stored in the Datastore,
some property that's stored
in the Datastore.
Well, one solution there
is to store multiple versions
of that string, right?
You store it
in the natural form,
the one that you
want to actually show
to your users in your UI.
And then you store it
in the upper case form,
which is the one that's going
to support the query.
Yes, it's duplication.
But you're pushing
the processing onto the writes
in order to execute
a more efficient read.
Let's talk about
the easier direction.
Migrating things off
of App Engine.
Of course we're sad
to see anyone go
but we know this is gonna happen
and it really is
important to us
that you feel like you can
take your code someplace else.
So the reason that this
is the easier direction
is that when it comes
to persistence,
App Engine is generally
more restrictive
than the environment
that you're probably porting to.
And the environment
you're probably porting to
is a relational database.
So when it comes to queries,
the App Engine Datastore
doesn't support joins.
Relational databases
typically support joins.
It's more restrictive.
You're using a subset
of the query functionality
of a relational database
when you're building
on the Datastore.
Similarly for transactions--
Entity group transactions
are more restrictive
than global transactions.
Multiple updates.
App Engine Datastore,
one update per Entity.
In a relational database,
you can probably update
an Entity as many times
as you like.
So it's more restrictive.
So the fact that you have
been developing against a subset
means that when you take it
to this other place,
more things are going to work.
That's good.
We're happy about that.
The biggest thing that you're
going to need to decide
when you're building
your application on App Engine
is what portability
means to you.
And once you've decided
what it means to you
then you need to decide
how important it is to you.
So there's multiple valid
definitions of portability.
One definition could just be,
"I want compile time
portability."
"I don't want to have
any com Google App Engine
import statements anywhere
in my code."
That doesn't necessarily mean
that you can build it
and just deploy it
into some other environment.
But you don't have any compile
time dependencies on App Engine.
That might be your definition
of portability.
You might have a definition
that says,
"Not only do I not want to have
compile time dependencies,
"I want to be able
to just change
"some configuration file
and be able to deploy that
into some other environment."
Again, that's a perfectly
reasonable definition
for portability.
It might be that you want
to have a single binary
that you build it,
you deploy it to App Engine,
you deploy it to WebSphere,
and you do nothing to it.
That's another definition
of portability.
And depending on which one
of those you choose,
or you may have some other
definition,
that is going to have
a lot of impact
on how you design things.
The nice thing is that no matter
what your definition is,
you've already sharded
your data model.
And if you happen to be
an application
that has lots and lots of data,
and you would need
to be horizontally partitioned
if you weren't running
on App Engine,
then you've already done
the hard work.
And that's great.
So let's look at a portable
model object.
Here's a root object.
It doesn't have a parent.
This is a JPA Entity.
It's a book.
There's a primary key.
It has a title.
And on the left we can see
what the physical model
looks like in the Datastore.
We've got our kind,
our Entity Group and key.
Entity Group and key
are the same.
That's how we know this
is a root Entity.
And there's the title,
and then on the right
we have our simple book table
which has its primary key
and a title of Vineland.
For child, yeah,
it looks a little bit uglier.
But we do have compile time
portability here.
We have added this
DataNucleus-specific extension.
It's not an App Engine
extension.
To use this extension--
this is actually something
that DataNucleus gives you.
We can say, "Hey,
store the base 64 encoded
representation of the key
in this string object."
The reason we need to do that
is because
this one field needs
to uniquely identify a chapter.
And a chapter is a child object.
And for child objects
with App Engine,
the parent primary key is part
of the primary key
of the child.
So we need to embed
additional information in there.
So we're declaring it
as a string
and we're telling DataNucleus,
"Hey, I want additional stuff
in here."
But then we're also declaring
this additional property
a parent key.
This is similar to the thing
that enables you
to do ancestor queries.
We've got
this additional property
that says,
"Hey, I want to expose
the primary key of my parent."
When we translate this
to the physical model,
on the left-hand side,
again, we have a typical
child object here.
The key contains the parent key
and the child key.
And then our properties,
23 pages.
And then here's
our chapter table
with our composite primary key
consisting
of the ID of the chapter
and the ID of its parent
and then the columns.
So the key things
that I want you to take away
from this talk
as we're wrapping up--
First and foremost,
the App Engine Datastore
simplifies persistence.
It simplifies the development
of your application.
You get the rapid prototyping.
You get the rapid
typesafe prototyping
if you're using JDO and JPA
and implementing a soft schema.
And it simplifies the management
of those applications.
And yes, it simplifies
the management
of scalable applications.
But again, every application
needs to scale
to a certain degree.
It just depends on what
that target is.
You can use JDO and JPA
to implement a soft schema.
This is going to take something
that looks a little bit
unfamiliar,
a schema-less Datastore,
and establish the structure
on top of it to make it look
a little bit more
like what you're used to.
When you're thinking about
moving applications
onto App Engine,
denormalization
is not a dirty word.
Do not be afraid
to duplicate data.
This is a great way
to be able to execute
complicated, efficient queries
on App Engine.
And finally, when you're going
the other direction,
taking your code someplace else,
plan for portability.
Decide what your definition
of portability is,
and then stick to it
and you'll be in good shape.
And with that I will be happy
to take questions.
Here's a couple of links,
information,
ways that you can get
more information on App Engine.
And please, if you have feedback
for the talk,
visit that link down there
at the bottom.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
man: Hi.
Thank you for the talk.
It was very informative.
What I'm taking away from this
is most applications,
you could build them
on a relational database
or on App Engine if you
kind of think about it
the right way
for the underlying platform.
Could you identify
some kind of criteria
where you'd say if A, B, and C
are true,
then you're really
in this sweet spot
for relational database and
models making your life easier--
versus
if X, Y, and Z are true,
you're in the zone
where the App Engine model
is gonna make your life easier
and relational
is pushing a stone uphill.
Ross: Okay.
So first and foremost,
if you build on App Engine,
the whole management side,
the operational side
of dealing with persistence,
that's always gonna be better.
If you can get there,
the management side
is pretty much always
gonna be better.
You don't have to manage
your database servers anymore.
That alone is a big win.
But your question is
when does it make sense
to sort of work hard
to get to that point?
I would say this process
of looking at your data model
and identifying roots--
If you look at your data model
and you can't find any roots,
everything is just pointing
every which way,
that is going
to be a challenging port.
Because the transactional
functionality,
and to a certain extent
the querying functionality,
sort of assumes that
you can slice your data,
that you can partition
your data.
So if that part goes badly,
then you may not be
in a good spot.
If that part goes really well,
then I would say, you know,
go forward.
Wait until you hit
the next bump.
I can't stand up here and say
it's always gonna be
straightforward.
It's always gonna be easy.
What I'm hoping to do
is get the conversation started
about what are the common
strategies,
what are the common patterns.
And the product's been out
I think eight weeks now,
so we're still pretty young.
But one of the things
that I'm really hopeful for
is that we see the community,
and I'm happy
to kick this off,
but I'd like to see
the community
start putting together
essentially a cookbook
of what types of things
we should be looking for
and how to move
those things over.
Yes?
man: Thank you for the talk.
I saw another talk yesterday
on distributive transactions.
Ross: Yes.
man: And I was wondering
if you had any thoughts on that
and how it applied to...
Ross: It applies really nicely.
So I saw Dan Wilkerson's talk
yesterday too.
For those who didn't see it,
there is an existing algorithm
for implementing distributive
transactions
on top of the App Engine
Datastore.
And it was done entirely
in user land.
Like, above the low-level
Datastore APIs.
Which is why Dan
was able to do it
because he doesn't work
for Google.
If you really need
global transactions,
in theory, this will help.
So I have not tried out
his implementation.
So I cannot say either way
sort of what the additional
storage cost is,
what the additional
performance cost is.
Based on what I know of it,
there is definitely some
additional storage cost.
There is definitely some
additional performance cost.
But I can't say to what degree
and how those things
are affected by data volume,
by the size and shape
of your data.
So we're gonna have to see.
I'm really looking forward
to that code
being made available
and I hope people try it out.
It may work really,
really great for some people.
But yeah, keep an eye out
for it, definitely.
Yeah?
man: Hi.
To what extent have you guys
done work
on kind of prefetched rules
and hints
for the implementations
to be able to load
kind of large graphs in one go
rather than kind
of ripple loading?
Ross: Yeah.
Well, so "in one go"
means something different
for the Datastore than it does
for a relational database.
If you're using JPA and you say,
"I want you to fetch
this relationship eagerly,"
that typically translates
to a join, right?
But the App Engine Datastore
doesn't support join,
so even if you said,
"I want it eagerly,"
that would just result
in multiple queries
done up front versus
multiple queries spread out
as the thing is used.
I'm not...
I'm not sure how much value
there would be
in sort of executing
multiple queries up front
versus executing multiple
queries as needed.
man: What I was getting at
was not the API side
but the back end side.
I guess another way of asking
are there any plans
in the road map
for supporting a means
to be able
to prefetch and do kind of
bulk operations like that?
Whether you call it a joiner
or some other--
Ross: We already support
batch gets.
We already support batch
inserts.
But for queries, we don't have
any immediate plans
to allow you to issue
a query that will, uh...
I don't know how else
to describe it
other than a join query.
That's typically what
you end up expressing.
But for individual records
there are batch operations
available already.
We have not yet exposed
those batch--
Actually, not true.
Batch gets are exposed in JDO.
In JPA, the batch puts
even though the interfaces--
they have things like
make persistent to all
or persist all--
they do not yet take advantage
of those batch operations.
But that's just because
we haven't implemented it yet.
So we'll get better with those,
but for the hard stuff
it's tough to say.
man: Thanks.
Ross: Yeah.
man: You talked about
the suggestion
of making user your Entity root
so that you could have
transactions
among any of the children
underneath there.
But that seems--there must be
performance implications
if suddenly
I just have that up here
and everything grows
underneath that as children,
there need to be some downsides.
So is that really that easy,
or what are some
of the penalties,
performance or space
or otherwise?
Ross: So it depends
on the access patterns
of the data, right?
If this is email, typically
you are accessing your email.
You are reading email.
You are writing email.
And chances are other people
are not hopefully
reading and writing your email.
Which means that you don't
have to worry quite so much
about concurrency
because it's you,
so you could be on multiple
computers at the same time.
But chances are it's just you.
In that sort of model,
then yeah,
user is a great choice.
But if you have something
that really does require
a lot of concurrent
modification,
then that's when you need
to really think harder.
The reason I say use user
if it works
is because
it's part of a domain
that is commonly there
and it might work out great.
That's sort of like
a best case scenario for you.
But it may not be
the average case.
Yeah.
Question?
man: Yeah,
it's a question again
about distributive
transactions.
Ross: Yeah.
man: In the future,
do you plan
on using distributive
transactions under the hood
inside the JDO or JPA
so that you can support
some of these other queries
that you can't support--
support joins and so forth?
So I don't have to worry
about distributive transactions.
The library would do it for me.
Ross: Right.
So if...
If we can get the--
excuse me.
If we can get
the throughput we need
from distributive transactions
then I would absolutely want
to bake them in
in a way that meant
you had to think about it
as little as possible.
But again, it starts
with what impact it has
on how much data is stored
and the performance
implications.
And I'm in no position to guess.
man: Yeah, I haven't used
your storage framework,
but what kind of performance
can we get?
How many writes on a given--
is it what you call
Entity Group?
Ross: On a given Entity Group
it's one--
man: For a small object,
you know?
Ross: So the rule of thumb
is you can expect 1 to 10--
you can expect to be able
to execute 1 to 10 writes
per second on an Entity Group.
Next question.
man: So I've been converting
a BADIs application
in the last eight weeks,
at least the down layer,
over to App Engine.
And the existing data model
has a few unowned relationships
and many-to-many relationships.
And I've been trying to isolate
them and whatnot.
I noticed today you said
you're not as of yet allowed
to do in queries.
So with a situation
like many-to-many,
what kind of approach
would you take
to get a collection
of something
only given a collection?
Ross: If I'm understanding
your question correctly,
multi-value properties
can be really helpful here.
If you have a many-to-many
and you have the list of keys
on one side,
or even on both sides,
then if you think back
to that contains example
that I showed where I said,
"Show me everybody
who considers yoga
to be a hobby."
That query will work great
for your scenario
based on those keys.
You can say, "Show me
all of the people
who consider this person
a friend."
That will basically give you
all of the people
that have this particular key
in that collection.
man: This is sort
of a bidirectional situation
where you really don't have--
you can't really trust
that you'll be able to write
both at any given time.
Well, you can trust one side
but not the other.
Is there a way of hashing
or caching
or something like that
that you could...
Ross: I'd have to think
about it more.
man: Okay, thank you.
Ross: If you post your question
on the message groups,
I will think about it more
and I'll try to get you
a better answer, yeah.
man: This is kind
of a follow-up question
to his question.
For migrating something
like Hibernate or iBatis
that has support for JPA
but also has
its own proprietary annotation
and query language,
if you were to move
to Google App Engine
and migrate away
from the annotations
of whatever ORM tool
you're using to JPA,
is there any options
for a neutral query tool
for building up
or is it part of JPA itself?
Or, like, some good way
of having criteria query
for Hibernate and something
on the App Engine side--
if you can still use Hibernate,
but if you wanted
to use something more neutral
in case you wanted
to pull it out later
and switch to something else?
Ross: I'm not sure
I completely understand.
So you want to leave your
Hibernate-specific code
in place?
man: You don't want to
but you kind of have to
unless you want to migrate
to something else, or if--
You're gonna want to get away
from conventions
of Hibernate because it keeps
you thinking in Hibernate
versus something more neutral.
Ross: The migration path
I would recommend there
is as you said, right?
Hibernate is a JPA
in limitation.
So I would migrate up
to JPA, still use Hibernate,
get to that point,
and then move over.
I think that's how
I would approach it.
I can't think of--
I wouldn't recommend a shortcut.
man: Okay.
Thank you.
Ross: Sure.
Okay, last two questions.
And if there are people here
who have questions
but you haven't stood up,
there's a fireside chat
in the fireside chat room
with the App Engine team,
like, right after this.
So just come on over there
and you can ask more questions.
Yes.
man: In JDO or JPA
implementation,
the DataNucleus implementation,
does it do dirty field detection
and only write the dirty fields
when you're doing an update
or does it need to write
the whole Entity?
Ross: So DataNucleus
does dirty field detection,
and DataNucleus then tells
the App Engine plug-in,
"Hey, write
just this one field,"
and then we write
the entire Entity
because the Datastore
does not support updates
at that level of granularity.
man: Okay, thanks.
Ross: Yep.
man: Just to be
a bit more clear,
you did talk in JDO/JPA
addressing the ownership.
So a person owns
multiple pets,
and a pet can only be owned
by one person.
But how about a situation
where the Entity Group
is actually like
an intelligence organization?
Say you have an Entity Group
for KGB and one for FBI.
And then you have James Bond,
Bruno, Borat--
they're all spies.
And then you have top secret
documents, maybe ten of them.
Can you within a transaction
using JDO or JPA
associate Bruno with the three
documents he just checked out
and Bond with the two documents
he just returned,
and do that all within JDO,
do I have to go
to a lower level?
Ross: You can do it
all through JDO,
but you will have
to explicitly--
you will have to explicitly
define your model objects
containing keys of some
of these other objects
as opposed to the type
of the object itself.
man: So you're saying, like,
for example
the documents can only
be checked out by one person.
So I guess that'd be
a traditional foreign key
and a database.
But for the person
checking out the books,
he'd have a multi-valued
property
that's just a list of the things
they have.
And JDO can handle that
out of the box.
Ross: JDO can handle that fine.
You just have to take care--
So you've asked
an interesting question.
So we use ownership
to imply Entity Groups.
But that is not the only way
to set up Entity Group
relationships.
It's just
a nice default value.
So it is possible
to have documents
as part of an Entity Group
and people as part
of the same Entity Group,
and have an unowned relationship
between those documents
and those people,
and have those documents
and people still reside
in the same Entity Group.
man: And JDO can handle
establishing the relationships
and de-establishing them
just fine.
Well, I had kind of like
a zero-one in one way
and then one-to-many
in the other.
How about for many-to-many?
Just like this spy's my friend,
this spy's not my friend.
Ross: So any time
it is not an actual ownership
relationship,
you don't need to dip down
to the low-level API.
You can do all of this
using JDO.
But again, you can't define
your model objects
in terms of other--
You can't define
the relationships
in terms
of other model objects.
You have to define
the relationships,
these unowned relationships,
using their primary keys.
man: So it would just be
you're storing streams
or numbers instead of--
Ross: You're storing unique IDs
for these things,
for the relationships.
And that is not
a limitation of JDO.
That is a limitation
of our implementation thus far.
So eventually we want
to get to the point
where you can say,
"Yeah, this person has
an association
with this document."
As opposed to this person
has a field
that happens to contain the
primary key of this document.
We want to get to that point.
We just haven't done it yet.
man: And just to extend this
a little bit more
on the limitation, let's say
we do have a social graph
and this spy has many friends
and these friends each have
their favorite restaurant.
I want to find
all the candidate restaurants
of all my friends
to decide where to go to lunch.
So I have to in one step
get all my friends.
And then I have to go query
each of them.
Load each of them separately
to get their set
of favorite restaurants
and then form my unique set.
Ross: There's probably room
for a batch get somewhere
in there where you can
provide a bunch of IDs
and pull back a bunch
of records in one shot.
man: So I can get
all my friends
and then specify all my friends
in the batch
and get back all their objects.
Ross: So it's not
a batch query.
Like, get me people identified
by 23, 29, and 34.
Get me all of those people.
man: And the full Entity
they represent,
then I can dive down and get
the specific things I want.
Thanks a lot.
Ross: Yep.
I think we're out of time.
But if you want to come over
to the fireside chat,
or we can just talk
as we walk over there.
But I think we're done up here.
Thank you.
[applause]